This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一档 I-Heart 播客。“百分之二”。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇特的现代世界中，如何培养心理韧性、保持健康以及建立抗压能力。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。也就是在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 TWO. percent。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. does not mean that you need to listen to learn the hard way on the aha radio app apple podcast or
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at It。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Kear Games。这个节目旨在探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的有资质的专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着你必须这样做。并不意味着你需要——在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 上收听 Learn the Hard Way，或者
wherever you get your podcast hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s the podcast where we talk through some of the big changes and transitions about 20s and what they mean for our psychology great another week another episode um this week the people have spoken and what they want to hear it is drum more please the psychology of cheating so buckle in friends because I don't think this is an easy or light topic like last weeks we are talking about dishonesty unfaithfulness and hurt that occurs in our most precious relationships and if you've been cheated on if you haven't hope you still kind of find something interesting about this um I've kind of brought in a lot of different theories This one was actually really interesting to research.
无论你在哪里收听播客，你好，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个我们探讨20多岁时的重大变化和过渡期以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。太棒了，又是一周，又是一期节目。嗯，本周，民意呼声很高，大家最想听的是——请敲鼓——出轨心理学！所以朋友们，请系好安全带，因为我觉得这不像上周那样是一个轻松或轻松的话题。我们在讨论最珍贵关系中出现的不诚实、不忠和伤害。如果你曾被背叛过，如果你没有，我希望你依然能从中发现一些有趣的东西。嗯，我引入了许多不同的理论。这个研究起来其实真的很有趣。
We've got theories from biological psychology, behavioral psychology, personality psychology, social psychology. So it's a bit of a doozy. Additionally, if you hear some ruckus in the background, it's Christmas season, and for those who know me, I live across the road from a pub. So everyone's partying. I actually show around Bill Shorten there the other day, so Bill Shorten's getting in on the Christmas spirit. But yeah, there might be some noise filtering in. Doesn't matter. We're here to learn.
我们有来自生物心理学、行为心理学、人格心理学、社会心理学的理论。所以内容相当丰富。另外，如果你听到背景中有一些喧闹声，那是圣诞季，对于了解我的人来说，我住在一家酒吧的对面。所以每个人都在狂欢。前几天我实际上还在那看到了比尔·肖顿，所以比尔·肖顿也融入了圣诞的气氛中。但是，是的，可能会有一些噪音渗透进来。没关系。我们是来学习的。
So, yeah, the psychology of cheating. So I heard this statistic on this podcast I was listening to the other day. 50% of relationships will involve an act of infidelity. And I think we hear about cheating a lot in our 20s as an explanation for why people have broken up or why you shouldn't date someone. Oh, you know, they cheat on their last partner. Like, he's a scumbag, that kind of thing. So let's deep dive into why. Why does this occur? Are people who cheat bad people?
所以，是的，出轨心理学。我前几天在听的一个播客上听到了这个统计数据：50% 的关系会涉及某种形式的不忠。我想我们在20多岁时经常听到关于出轨的说法，以此来解释为什么人们分手了，或者为什么你不应该和某人约会。哦，你知道的，他们背叛了前任。就像，他是个混蛋，诸如此类。所以让我们深入探讨一下原因。为什么会发生这种事？出轨的人是坏人吗？
Is the phrase, once a cheater, always a cheater, correct? I think it's time to investigate. So cheating, for those who have experienced this, is pretty terrible. I think it's a lot like a big trope in movies and songs, pop culture, folklore. We see it all around us. We see it quite often. It's up for discussion, and I feel like it's quite ubiquitous. But for people in those situations, I think nothing about it feels like something someone else could understand or rationalise to you.
“一次不忠，终身不用”这句话对吗？我想是时候深入调查一下了。所以，对经历过这种事的人来说，出轨是非常糟糕的。我想这很像电影、歌曲、流行文化和民间传说中的一大老套路。我们周围到处都能看到它。我们经常看到它。这是一个可以公开讨论的话题，我觉得它无处不在。但对于处于那种情况中的人来说，我觉得关于它的任何事情都不像是别人能够理解或为你合理化的。
It's one of those experiences that is common, I would say, what we, 50% of people or 50% of relationships. But really isolating and unique in how emotionally destructive and undermining it can be. And I think the emotional aftermath is much like the stages of grief, the shock, denial, anger, but hopefully the acceptance. obviously pending maybe some long-term interpersonal damage. I think something that is really interesting when we talk about cheating is that people have different conceptions of it. Often we think of cheating as like a physical act, but cheating isn't just sex.
我想，这是那种很常见的经历之一，也就是我们所说的，50%的人或50%的关系。但在其带来的情感破坏性和消极影响方面，它又是极其孤立和独特的。我认为情感上的余波非常类似于悲伤的几个阶段，即震惊、否认、愤怒，但希望最终能接受。当然，这可能还有待一些长期的个人关系损害。我认为我们在谈论出轨时一个非常有趣的现象是，人们对它有着不同的概念。通常我们认为出轨是一种身体上的行为，但出轨并不仅仅是性。
It can also be emotional disclosure. And I think we have this idea of cheating as this physical act or sexual intimacy. And that's actually not probably, I would say, the most important area of our romantic relationship. sex is just one part, but it's the emotional closeness that sex kind of comes along with is just a natural expression of that. So I think the thing that we also need to talk about whilst we're talking about physical cheating is emotional cheating. And that can kind of look like secretive, sustained closeness with someone who's not your primary partner.
它也可以是情感的倾诉。我想我们对出轨的固有印象是这种身体行为或性亲密。而这实际上可能并不是——我想说——我们恋爱关系中最重要的一块。性只是其中一部分，但性所伴随的情感亲密，其实只是这种亲密的自然表达。所以我觉得我们在谈论身体出轨的同时，也需要谈论情感出轨。这看起来可能像是与你的主要伴侣之外的人保持着秘密的、持续的亲密关系。
And in some ways, I can imagine that it's worse. Sex without emotion is not uncommon, but a deep, at times non-sexual, emotional, intimacy can mean so much more and possibly undermines a relationship more than a mere physical act. And I think the reason why we react to physical cheating is, firstly, the absolute like a front to notions like loyalty and trust and honesty that we want in our romantic relationships. But also, it's the idea that sex could lead to more. It could leave to someone leaving. It could leave to your relationship breaking down and that emotional intimacy between you and your
在某些方面，我可以想象这更糟糕。没有感情的性并不罕见，但有时这种非性的、深厚的情感亲密意味着更多，并且可能比单纯的身体行为对关系的破坏更大。我想我们对身体出轨作出反应的原因，首先是对我们希望在恋爱关系中得到的忠诚、信任和诚实等观念的绝对挑衅。但这也是因为这种想法：性可能会导致更多的事情。它可能导致某人离开。它可能导致你们的关系破裂，导致你和伴侣之间的情感亲密感崩溃。
partner kind of crumbling. Interestingly, fun fact, but not that fun, men tend to get more upset about physical infidelity whilst women are more concerned with cheating that is associated with intense emotional disclosure. And some psychologists have suggested that this stems from the primitive reason behind why we take partners or accept monogamy to begin with. So men want to ensure monogamy so that they know their offspring are actually theirs for genetic purposes. Whilst women, you know, biologically, this is a genetic evolutionary argument, but women, they want a partner or a mate who will be loyal and stick around and provide support.
有趣的是，一个有趣但并不那么有趣的事实是，男性往往对身体上的不忠感到更沮丧，而女性则更关注与强烈情感倾诉相关的出轨。一些心理学家认为，这源于我们最初选择伴侣或接受一夫一妻制的原始原因。因此，男性希望确保一夫一妻制，这样他们出于基因的目的就知道他们的后代实际上是他们自己的。而女性，你知道的，从生物学上讲，这是一个基因进化的论点，但女性希望有一个忠诚、守在身边并提供支持的伴侣或配偶。
And I think with most evolutionary explanations, this does tend to be a bit outdated and doesn't really keep up with how we understand gender roles in reproduction and mateship nowadays, but it's still an interesting theory from kind of an evolutionary area of psychology. I think with emotional cheating, we do have to be careful about calling any type of emotional attachment to someone that isn't your primary partner, a form of cheating. I think it's really important to have people who aren't your partner you can share things with and that have that level of openness, but it's about boundaries. You know, if your partner is spending hours alone with someone having deep, meaningful,
我想，对于大多数进化论的解释来说，这往往有点过时，并且跟不上我们现在对性别角色、生殖和伴侣关系的理解，但它仍然是心理学进化领域的一个有趣的理论。我认为在面对情感出轨时，我们确实必须小心，不要把对任何不是你主要伴侣的人的某种情感依恋都称为一种出轨。我认为，拥有可以分享事情、达到这种开放程度的非伴侣朋友真的很重要，但关键在于界限。你知道的，如果你的伙伴和某人单独相处数小时，进行深入的、有意义的、关于死亡和父母离异的哲学对话，这可能会让你心烦，但可能不会惹恼其他人。这完全取决于你对那个人有什么期望，以及你如何定义你们关系的感情界限。但我也能理解为什么这会让人非常沮丧和心烦，并且显然值得以健康的方式进行沟通。始终在治疗中使用“我”开头的语言是一个理念。
philosophical conversations about death and your parents' divorce, that might upset you, but it might not upset someone else. It's all about what you expect from that person and how you have defined the emotional boundaries of your relationship. But I can see why that would be very frustrating and upsetting and worth communicating about them in a healthy way, obviously. Always using eye language as is an idea in therapy.
所以让我们来谈谈人们为什么会出轨。从心理学的角度来看，这真的很有趣。人们出轨的原因显然有很多，但根据这位女士——凯利·坎贝尔（Kelly Campbell）的说法，她是CSU（加州州立大学）的一名心理学副教授或教授，这些原因通常可以分为三类。所以人们出轨的原因可能是个人的、基于关系的或情境的。当我们谈论个人原因时，这些通常与一个人的个性有关，这可能会使他们更倾向于出轨。所以这通常是诸如你的性格特征、你的信仰、你的宗教信仰等因素。
So let's talk about why people cheat. This is really interesting from a psychological perspective. There are obviously many reasons why people cheat, but according to this woman, Kelly Campbell, she is I think an associate or professor of psychology at CSU, they usually fall into three categories. So the reasons people might cheat might be individual based on the relationship or situational. So when we talk about individual reasons, these often have something to do with a person's personality, which may make them more likely to cheat. So this is often factors like your personality traits, your beliefs, your religion.
例如，自恋的人更有可能出轨。曾有过这样一项针对大约4000人的大型研究，他们询问了他们的性历史，做了许多性格测试和评估，结果发现了这一点：自恋者更有可能出轨。顺便说一句，如果你想知道如何识别这些自恋者并在约会中避开他们，我曾为此做过一整集的节目。但简单总结一下，自恋者无法自然地感受到同理心，并且经常把人当作达到目的的手段。所以也许那是他们的伴侣或他们出轨的对象。因此他们可能更容易
For example, someone who is narcissistic is more likely to cheat. There was this big study of like 4,000 people and they asked them about their sexual history, did a bunch of personality tests and assessments, and they found this, that narcissists are more likely to cheat. Side note, I did a whole episode on this if you want to know how to identify these narcissistic people and steer clear of them and your dating last. but a quick summary, a narcissist can't naturally feel empathy and often uses people as means to an ends. So maybe that's their partner or the person they're cheating with. So they may be more prone
无法考虑甚至（你知道的）不在乎他们的性不忠所带来的后果。我认为通常值得注意的是，这更往往是性不忠，因为对于自恋者以及那些无法在情感层面上与其他人建立联系的人来说，情感出轨可能非常罕见。另一个个人因素是那些有依恋、承诺或自尊问题的人。正如我刚才提到的2016年这项研究所表明的那样，他们似乎也更有可能出轨。因此，渴望提升自尊可以成为不忠的动力。与一个新的人发生性关系，去了解一个新的人，可以带来非常积极的内在感受。
to not being able to consider or even, you know, care about the consequences of their sexual infidelity. I think it's often worth noting that it would be sexual infidelity more often than not because emotional cheating would probably be very rare for a narcissist and someone who can't relate to other people on an effective and emotional level. Another individual factor is people with attachment, commitment or self-esteem issues. They also seem to be more likely to cheat as this 2016 study I was talking about has suggested. So wanting a boost to self-esteem can motivate infidelity. having sex with a new person, getting to know a new person can lead to really positive internal feelings.
你可能会感到赋权、有吸引力、自信或成功，当你以前可能没有那么多这些感觉时，这些感觉都会在某种程度上建立你的自尊。在某些情况下，难以做出承诺的人也可能更容易出轨。我也认为同样重要的是，因为承诺并不意味着同一件事。对每个人来说。你知道，恋爱关系中的两个人对关系状态有非常不同的看法是完全可能的，比如它是随意的、专一的等等。我也认为，真正喜欢一个人但仍然害怕向他们做出承诺是可能的。在这种情况下，一个伴侣可能最终会以逃避承诺的方式出轨，即使他们本能地更愿意留在那种关系中。所以这就是出轨的类型。人们出轨的原因是，
You might feel empowered, attractive, confident or successful and these feelings all kind of build up your self-esteem when you may not have had much previously. People who have a hard time with commitment may also be more likely to cheat in some cases. I think also importantly because commitment just doesn't mean the same thing. to everyone. You know, it's possible for two people in a relationship to have very different ideas about the relationship status, such as whether it's casual, exclusive and so on. I think it's also possible to really like someone and still fear making a commitment to them. And in this case, one partner might end up cheating as a way of avoiding commitment, even if they would naturally prefer to stay in that relationship. So this was the type of cheating. The reason people cheat is, it's
从个人角度来看。而第二种出轨的原因是由于关系问题，而不是出轨者内在的一些东西。它是关于你们作为一对伴侣之间的现状，你们关系的现状。研究人员一次又一次地发现，那些以不满足、性生活不满足和高度冲突为特征的伴侣关系，
from an individual perspective. And the second type of cheating is due to relationship issues rather than something internally about the person who's been cheating. It's about the state of things between you as a pair, the state of your relationship. Researchers have found time and time again that partnerships that are characterized by dissatisfaction, unfulfilling sex, and high conflict,
他们面临不忠的风险往往更高。此外，伴侣在性格、教育水平和共同点方面的差异越大，他们经历不忠的可能性就越大。如果存在未满足的需求，或者坠入爱河的微光喜悦不再维持你们的羁绊，出轨可能会变得更有可能，因为来自伴侣的内啡肽和多巴胺的冲动和强度正在对另一个人消退。但是，在这些情况下，你仍然不必出轨。如果你不再爱一个人，你总是可以和他们分手，或者讨论开放式关系，而不是背叛伴侣对你的信任或你们关系中一夫一妻制的忠诚。我想这是我总是会说的一点，就像如果你打算对某人不忠，你为什么不直接和他们分手呢？我想这是我们许多人都会想的事情，为什么你不能直接和他们分手呢？这就引出了人们出轨的第三个原因，也就是情境原因。有时人们并不是出去寻找其他人来肯定自己，寻找性，寻找情感倾诉。所以情境原因，这是指某人出轨了，但他们并没有容易出轨的性格。你们的关系很好，但他们的环境中的某些东西使他们面临不忠的风险。所以考虑一下这个场景。你对最近关系中的疏离感到非常沮丧。也许你们是
they're often at a higher risk for infidelity. Also, the more dissimilar partners are in terms of personality and education level and things in common, the more likely they are to experience infidelity. If there are unmet needs or this glimmering euphoria of falling in love is no longer kind of sustaining your bond, cheating may become more likely because the rush and intensity of endorphins and dopamine from you as a partner is fading for that other person. but still you don't have to cheat in these situations if you don't love someone anymore you can always break up with them or discuss an open relationship instead of betraying your partner's trust in you or loyalty in the monogamy of your relationship I think that's something
异地恋，你正在应对自尊心低下和对外表的不安感，而有一天，比如一个同事或大学里的某人变得对你非常友好，把你独自拦下，并说了一些诸如“我真的被你吸引了，让我们什么时候在一起吧”之类的话。如果只有一两个因素参与其中，你可能不会选择出轨——例如，如果只是这种情况——但这种激励因素的组合（你知道的，你们关系中的距离，这是一个关系问题；你对自己的外表、自尊的感觉，这是一个个人问题；
I always say like if you're going to cheat on someone why don't you just break up with them I think that's something a lot of us think like why don't you just break up with them and this kind of leads to the third reason people cheat which is situation reasons. Sometimes people aren't going out there looking for someone else to validate them, looking for sex, looking for emotional disclosure. So situational reasons, this refers to someone who cheats, but they don't have a personality that's prone to cheating. Your relationship is fine, but something about their environment puts them at a risk for infidelity. So like consider this scenario. You're really frustrated with the recent distance in your relationship. Maybe you're
还有那个情境因素，同事的注意）会使不忠更有可能发生。所以我想，哪个原因最糟糕？也许这是我们想问的问题。但我认为我们并不是真的在这里对此进行评判。我认为情感结果都是一样的，尤其是在我们20多岁的时候，许多关系
long distance and you're dealing with feelings of low self-esteem and your appearance and one day like a co-worker or someone at uni becomes really friendly with you and catches you alone and says something like I'm really attracted to you like let's get together sometime you might not choose to cheat if only one or two factors were involved so for example if it was just the situation but this combination of motivating factors you know the distance in your relationship which is a relationship issue, your feelings about your impureance, self-esteem, a personal individual issue,
具有高度的形成性，被背叛的关系会对你未来的信任能力和对承诺的自我认知产生许多二阶后果，我想这就是为什么讨论这可能不是你的错并且不要对你的伴侣不忠是如此重要。也许有些事情需要说出来，希望我们都在同一页上。但是还有一个我们可以具体应用于出轨的观点——人们为什么会出轨——我发现这真的很有趣。它经常出现在关于恋爱、性和
and that situational factor, the attention of your co-worker can make infidelity more likely. So which reason is the worst, I guess? Maybe that's a question we want to ask. But I don't think we're really here to pass judgment on that. I think the emotional outcome is all the same, especially in our 20s when many of your relationships
诸如此类的心理学中。它被称为爱的三角形理论。因此，爱的三角形理论表明，爱可以根据三个组成部分来理解，这三个组成部分合在一起可以被视为形成三角形的顶点。所以如果你把手举成一个三角形，我来解释一下。在一边，我们有亲密感。下一边，我们有。下一边，我们有激情，最后一边我们有决定和承诺。这就是建立一段好关系的原因，但当这些边之一失效时，例如亲密感，或者你不再对某人感到那种激情，或者冲突和出轨等事情打破了三角形的和谐，这就是关系可能失败的时候，我们可能会看到更高程度的
are highly formative, a relationship in which you've been, cheated on can have many second order consequences on your ability to trust in the future and your own perceptions of commitment which is think is why it's so important to kind of chat about how it's probably not your fault and don't cheat on your partners maybe that's something that needs to be said hopefully we all are on the same page there but there is another idea that we can apply to cheating specifically why people cheat that I found really fascinating. And it comes up a lot in psychology around relationships and sex and
不忠。所以再次谈到这位了不起的心理学家凯利·坎贝尔，人们出轨的原因有很多，但她在她写的一篇文章中很快指出，这实际上不应该被妖魔化。她提出了这个观点：我们甚至不知道人类是否注定是一夫一妻制的。只是有些人天生更符合这些观点，而另一些人则不然。所以这有点像那个古老的问题：出轨会让你成为一个坏人吗？我们的本能反应可能会说是的，当然会。你不应该对你爱的人不忠。当你与某人有联系，当你同意排他性时，不兑现这一点并伤害另一个人是非常糟糕的。但就像所有事情一样，有很多灰色地带。而且我认为在某些方面，
things like that. And it's called the triangular theory of love. So the triangular theory of love suggests that love can be understood in terms of three components that together can be kind of viewed as forming the vertices of a triangle. So if you put your hands up in a triangle, I'll explain. So on one side, we've got intimacy. The next side, we have. The next side, we have have passion and the final side we have decision and commitment. This is what creates a good relationship but when one of these sides fails, for example intimacy or you no longer feel that passion for someone or things like conflict and cheating pierce the harmony of the triangle, that's when the relationship is probably going to fail and we might see greater degrees of
存在着灰色地带，关于如果你以前出轨过，这是否会让你一辈子都是个出轨者，或者对某人的不忠是否可以原谅。如果我们把出轨称为错误，我们是否会允许人们在恋爱关系中犯错。还有一件事是什么构成出轨？另一个巨大的问题，我们真的把这些都抛给你们了，是我们赋予出轨的罪恶感纯粹是文化的吗？是因为财产权、教堂和宗教建立的一夫一妻制制度吗？这就是我们接下来要讨论的。
infidelity. So talking again about this amazing psychologist Kelly Campbell, there are a myriad of that people cheat, but she's really quick to point out in this article that she wrote that it shouldn't actually be demonized. She makes this point. We don't know if humans are even meant to be monogamous. It's just that some people are naturally more in line with those views and others are not. So that's kind of the age old question. Does cheating make you a bad person? And our natural instinct might be to say yes, of course it does. You shouldn't cheat on someone you love. When you have a bond with someone when you have a greed on exclusivity, not honoring that and hurting the other person is pretty terrible. But like everything, there's a lot of gray area. And I think in some ways,
“一次不忠，终身不用”这句话可能并非如此。人们会犯错，他们是否会再次犯罪，或者对同一个或不同的伴侣再次出轨。这取决于他们在内部以及有时在无意识中如何合理化自己的行为。这与认知失调背后的心理学有很大关系。所以你是否会再次出轨，取决于你在第一次行为后如何改变对承诺或伴侣的态度。因此，在艰难的道德决定之后减少失调，会导致人们在未来表现得更具道德或更不道德。因此，以出轨为例，在你对某人不忠之后，无论这种行为在未来变得更可能还是更不可能，都会根据你的态度以及你试图证明你的道德选择合理性的方式而有所不同。因此，如果你对某人不忠，特别是如果你被抓包了，你可能会觉得自己太糟糕了。
there's gray area about whether if you've cheated before, that makes you a cheater for life, or whether cheating on someone is forgivable. Do we kind of allow people to make mistakes in relationships if we can call cheating that. And something else is like what constitutes cheating? And another huge question, we're really loading them off on you, is, is the evil that we kind of assigned to cheating purely cultural because of the institution of monogamy that's been created by property rights and the church and religion? That's what we're going to discuss next.
如果你是一个好人，一个有道德的人，我想这会与我们如何看待自己产生冲突：作为关系中值得信赖的人，作为好的、受人尊敬的、忠诚的人。因此，我们在自我认知和行为之间体验到这种失调。认知失调是心理学中的一个术语，我们将试图通过淡化你所选择的行为的方面来为某种行为辩护。所以这是你得以
The phrase, once a cheater, always a cheater, might not be true. People can make mistakes and whether they reoffend, I guess, or cheat again on the same or a different partner. It depends on how they rationalise their actions internally and at times unconsciously. And this has a lot to do with the psychology behind cognitive dissonance. So whether you cheat again will depend on how you change your attitude towards commitment or your partner after that first act. So dissonance reduction following a difficult moral decision can cause people to behave either more or less ethically in the future. So using the cheating example, after you cheat on someone, whether that behavior becomes more or less likely you'll cheat in the future will differ based on your attitudes and how you attempt to justify your ethical choice. So if you cheat on someone, especially if you get caught, you'll probably feel really terrible.
克服出轨带来的失调的方法之一。你可能会说，哦，这没那么糟糕。每个人都这样做。你淡化了这一行为的各个方面。因此，如果有人选择用这种逻辑来为自己的行为辩护，他们可能会再次这样做，因为他们有一些外部的理由或验证，这是由以下信念的强化带来的：这没那么糟糕，因为其他人也在这样做，因为每个人都在这样做。因为，你知道，你还能指望什么呢？然而，如果你将出轨归咎于个人缺陷并认识到这一点，（你知道的）这可能是因为你的自尊，可能是因为（你知道的）你们的关系中存在你可能需要负责任的紧张关系，你们没有公开沟通，这种外部验证就不复存在了。
and if you are a good person, a moral person, I guess it will conflict with how we like to see ourselves as trustworthy in a relationship, as good, as respected, as loyal. So we experience this dissonance between the perception of ourselves and our actions. Cognitive dissonance is the term in psychology, and we're going to try to justify an action by minimizing aspects of the action you have chosen. So that's one way that you get to.
如果你对自己说，你出轨是因为情境和内部因素，你可以控制这种行为，并且你可以看到这是一个你不想再犯的错误。这就是持久改变成为可能的时候，因为你创造了一个关于你自己的新的反向信念，其中不包括对伴侣的不忠。你已经决定这不是我是谁。这是由于情境因素，或者是由于我可以控制的事情，比如信心不足，而我可以改变这一点。这被称为自我说服，它创造了由这种自我合理化带来的持久态度改变。所以如果有人背叛了你，而你决定原谅他们。首先，上帝保佑你。永远原谅。但如果你担心
over that dissonance of cheating. You might say, oh, it's not that bad. Everyone does it. You minimize aspects of the action. So if someone chooses to justify their actions using this logic, they'll probably do it again because they have some form of external justification or validation that is brought on by the reinforcement of the belief that it's not that bad because other people are doing it, because everyone does it. Because, you know, what do you expect? However, if you subscribe cheating to a personal flaw and recognize that, that, you know, that maybe it's because of your self-esteem, maybe it's because, you know, there's tension in your relationship that you might be responsible for, you don't have open communication, that external validation is no longer
他们是否会再次出轨，和他们谈谈他们现在如何看待自己的行为可能很重要。如果他们说，哦，你知道，这没那么糟。我认为这比你想象的要普遍得多。我想这只是一次失误。他们可能还会这样做。但如果他们说，哦，天哪，这根本不是我。那真是个错误。我认为这是因为我们关系中的这个我想解决的问题。我决定这——这不是我想成为的人，这是因为这个，那么他们再次这样做的可能性就不大了。所以这真的取决于一个人选择走的路线。他们是为了尽量减少内疚而寻求外部还是内部的理由来为自己的行为辩护？
there. If you say to yourself that you cheated because of situational and internal factors, you can control that behavior and you can see that it was a mistake that you don't want to make again. This is when long-lasting change is possible because you've created a new counter-belief about yourself that does not include cheating on a partner. You've decided this is not who I am. It was because of a situational factor or because of something I can control like poor levels of confidence and I can change that. So this is called self-persuasion and it creates a long-lasting attitude change that results from this self-justification. So if someone's cheated on you and you've decided to forgive them. Firstly, God bless you. Forgiveness always. But if you're worried about
如果那个人感到内疚，好吧，那可能是因为你所处的关系对象可能是一个自恋者或一个具有相当阴险人格特征的人，这种人格特征表现为不忠，你可能不应该和那个人在一起。如果他们伤害了你却没有感到内疚，红旗。巨大的红旗。离开那里。但我认为永远重要的是要记住人类会犯错误，这包括你的伴侣。我认为，永远没有必要用完美的标准来要求你的伴侣，因为你总是会感到失望。你必须因为一个人本来的样子去爱他们，而不是因为你想让他们成为的样子。虽然不忠远谈不上完美，差得远呢。
whether they're going to cheat again, it's probably important to talk to them about how they see their actions now. If they say, oh, you know, it wasn't that bad. I think it's a lot more common than you think. I guess it was just a slip up. They probably will do it again. But if they say, oh my gosh, it's just not who I am. That was such a mistake. I think it was because of this issue in our relationship that I want to fix. I've decided that like this isn't, who I want to be, it was because of this, then it's unlikely that they'll do it again. So it really depends on the root a person chooses to take. Do they seek external or internal justification for their actions in order to minimize their guilt?
我认为你不应该总是彻底否定你的伴侣，因为他们在过去不忠过，或者以前在你们的关系中不忠过。显然，这是你的决定。但正如我们所说，有时出轨可能是因为自尊心低，或者他们可能会觉得需要来自
And if that person feels no guilt, well, it might be because the relationship you're in is with maybe a narcissist or someone with a pretty sinister personality trait that has manifested in. infidelity and you probably shouldn't stay with that person. If they've hurt you and they don't feel guilty, red flag. Big red flag. Get out of there. I think it is always important though to remember that humans make mistakes and that includes your partner. There is no use ever, I think, holding your partner to the standard of perfection because you'll kind of always be let down. You've got to love someone for who they are, not who you want them to be. And while infidelity is far from perfection, far.
关系之外某个人的关注，才能感到自己很有吸引力或很有价值。我觉得这似乎把责任归咎于你，认为你应该日夜不停地夸奖他们。但我认为，认识到这一点很重要：虽然出轨者最终应负主要责任，但确实有些事情会驱使某人出轨，所以当我们在评估出轨者犯下的错误时，考虑导致人们出轨的错误类型也很重要，以及思考也许你
I don't think you should always totally write off your partner because they've cheated in the past or they cheated before in your relationship. Obviously, this is your call. But like we said, sometimes cheating can be because of low self-esteem or they might feel as if they need attention
也可能做到这一点，如果你正处于一段恋爱关系中，你应该确保鼓励你的伴侣并向他们传达他们已经足够好了，并且值得你的爱，你知道的，我认为你的角色是为关系提供安全感，但再次强调，如果有人对你不忠，这不是你的错。这并不是因为你不够爱他们。那有点愚蠢。但同样，我认为如果有人越界或伤害了你，
from someone outside of the relationship to feel desirable or worthy. I think that kind of makes it seem like it's your fault that you should have been like hyping them up day and day night. But I think that, it's important to recognize that whilst the cheater is ultimately at fault there are things that can drive someone to cheat so while we are evaluating the mistakes that cheaters are making it's also important to consider the types of mistakes that lead people to cheat and whether maybe you could
就像我说的，这不是你的错。我认为，“人都会犯错”这种哲学绝不意味着你应该一笔勾销、既往不咎，特别是如果这造成了持久的损害或者你认为这个人可能会再次这样做的话。我认为你的内心平静可能不值得你留下来陪他们。
have done it as well and if you are in a relationship you should be sure to kind of encourage your partner and communicate to them that they are good enough and deserving of your love you know I think your kind of role is to provide security in a relationship but again not your fault if someone cheats on you. It's not because you didn't love them enough. That's kind of stupid. But again, I think if someone oversteps your boundary or hurts you,
也许这会促使你们重新评估关系并进行更好的沟通，但这可能并非总是可行的选项。现在让我们在接下来的内容中引入一些社会心理学，这是我最喜欢的。所以我们研究了生物学、我们的进化心理学。我们从自恋和行为心理学的角度研究了人格，但是什么构成了出轨，为什么我们对它如此反对？有明显的原因。我们不喜欢出轨是因为它伤害了我们，而且它太糟糕了、太逊了。但这种反应仅仅是因为我们被训练去期望一夫一妻制吗？
like I said, not your fault. I think, and in no way does the philosophy of people make mistakes, mean you should just forgive and forget, especially if it's caused lasting damage or you think this person could do it again. I think your peace is probably not worth staying with them.
对出轨行为的排斥是我们文化中根深蒂固的东西吗？我还认为人们对什么是出轨有不同的概念，首先确定这一点很重要。对某些人来说，如果他们的伴侣以非性爱的方式与其他人共度时光，但为了陪伴，那可能是（你知道的）某种非性爱的事情，就像我说的，这可能被视为出轨。然而对其他人来说，亲吻或调情可能没什么大不了的。或者在某些情况下，（你知道的）也许他们去看脱衣舞娘，或者他们和朋友或同性朋友亲热。
And maybe it will cause you guys to reassess your relationship and communicate better, but that might not always be an option. Now let's introduce some social psychology into the next, which is my favourite. So we've looked at biology, our evolutionary psychology. We've looked at personality in terms of narcissism and at behavioral psychology, but what constitutes cheating and why is it that we are so disproving of it? So there are obvious reasons. We don't like cheating because it hurts us, and it's awful and it sucks. But is that reaction only because we have been trained to expect monogamy?
这些事情在某些关系中可能是可以接受的，而在另一些关系中则不然。我对这种现象有点反感，比如有些男生会说：“噢，对啊，你知道的，我女朋友跟另一个女生接吻了，但这不算出轨。”因为他们有点贬低性冲动，尤其是当那个女性是双性恋的时候。就像，你知道的，我不知道。我觉得这有点问题，好像在说：“哦，就因为这是两个女性之间，所以我受到的冒犯就较少，而如果是跟男性的话——因为我把女性视为较小的威胁，因为我实际上并不尊重我女朋友的性取向。”
Is the rejection of cheating behaviour is something that is culturally ingrained in us? I also think people have different conceptions of what cheating is, and that's important to set up first. For some, if their partner were to spend time with someone else in a non-sexual way, but for company that could be, you know, something just non-sexual, like I said, that could be deemed as cheating. Whereas for others, things like kissing or flirting might not be a big deal. Or in context where, you know, maybe they go and see strippers or they're making out with a friend or a friend of the same gender.
无论如何，扯远了。但我认为关于什么算作出轨、什么不算的界限是高度主观的，它取决于你们作为情侣所做的决定。我不认为这可以通过反复试验来决定——完全不行。设定这些界限并让它们变得清晰。但我们要讨论的第二部分是，出轨真的那么糟糕吗，我们对它的反应是否只是因为某些社会规范而产生？所以感觉我们似乎花了（你知道的）过去一个世纪的时间来做出了一系列激进的社会变革，
These things may be okay in some relationships and not others. I do have kind of a problem with, like, guys being like, oh yeah, you know, my girlfriend, like, kissed another girl, but it's not cheating. because they kind of like undervalue, especially if that woman's bisexual, because they undervalue the sexual urges. Like, you know, I don't know. I think it's like a bit problematic to be like, oh, just because it's like between two women, I'm less offended, whereas if it was with a man, because I see women as less of a threat because I don't actually respect my girlfriend's sexuality.
这些变革在某种程度上动摇了一夫一妻制的圣洁性。我认为，情侣们比以往任何时候都更加公开、更加普遍地讨论他们关系的本质。而且我认为我们已经达到了这样一个阶段：恋爱关系并不像社会先前所期望的那样非黑即白。这是我的朋友卡罗莱娜（节目之友）告诉我的一个非常有趣的事情。在性别心理学和性别研究中有一种观点认为，一夫一妻制之所以出现，是因为围绕财产的法律和宗教的影响。因此，男性希望确保他们将遗产传给的后代确实是他们自己的。因此，出轨变得更加禁忌，尤其是对女性而言，因为这会破坏男性的性、情感、经济和身体权威。此外，随着宗教教义使性变得更加保守并希望它变得更加神圣，这把性和亲密关系限制在婚姻之内，人们因为打破这种一夫一妻和他们婚姻床榻的神圣性而感到羞耻。
Anyhow, a bit of a segue. But I think that line of what you see is cheating or not is highly subjective. and it's based on what you decide as a couple. I don't think that it's something that you can determine by trial and error, like, at all. Set those boundaries and make them clear. But kind of that second part we're talking about is, is cheating that bad, and do our reactions to it only come about because of certain social norms? So it feels like we've spent, you know, the past century making a slew of progressive social changes
所以我认为，由于这些机构和影响力的作用，历史上面对出轨所承受的文化羞辱和压力，或许造就了我们现在对出轨的感受。显而易见，这自然还是感觉不好，但正如我们所知，情绪和反应在很大程度上是由你的父母、同龄人和媒体在文化上决定的。如果历史曾提倡多元之爱和多伴侣或没有婚姻，也许作为增加人口和保持更大和谐的一种方式，那是我们的历史。也许围绕出轨的这些想法——顺便说一下，我仍然认为这他妈的相当可憎——但也许那些围绕出轨的想法会没那么负面，与其他人上床或与其他人有情感亲密会得到更多接受。我希望大家喜欢这集关于出轨心理学的简短节目。
that kind of undermine the sanctity of monogamy. I think it's more open and more common for couples to talk about the nature of their relationship than ever before. And I think we've reached a stage where relationships aren't as black and white as society has perhaps previously expected them to be. This is something really interesting that my friend Carolina, friend of the show, told me. There's this idea in gender psychology and in gender studies that monogamy arose because of laws around property and the influence of religion. So men wanted to ensure that the offspring they were passing their inheritance onto were actually theirs. And so cheating became more taboo, especially for women, because it would undermine male sexual, emotional, economic and physical authority. Also, as religious teachings made sex more conservative and wanted it to become more sacred, this restricted sex and intimacy into marriage, and people were shamed for breaking that sanctity of one man, one wife and their kind of marriage bed.
我认为出轨，尽管很艰难，但在我们的20多岁时却很常见，因为我们正在试探我们的界限，学习如何与伴侣沟通，并且可以说是第一次体验性、亲密感和情感倾诉。我们听到了很多关于它的故事。也许你经历过。所以我希望这能阐明它发生的原因，人们出轨背后的原因，但也表达了这样一种观点：我不认为这永远是某人的错，比如被出轨者的错。有这么多的
So I think the cultural humiliation and pressure not to cheat throughout history because of the influence of these institutions and influences has perhaps created the feelings we have now around cheating. Obviously, it's still, you know, naturally doesn't feel good, but emotions and reactions are, as we know, culturally conditioned in many ways from your parents, from your peers, from the media. And if history had promoted polyamory and multiple sexual partners or no marriage, Maybe as a way to increase population and keep greater harmony, and that was our history. Maybe these ideas around cheating, which by the way I still see is pretty fucking abhorrent, but maybe those ideas around cheating would be less negative, and the idea of sleeping with someone else or having emotional intimacy with someone else would be more accepted. I hope that we've enjoyed this kind of quick episode on the psychology of cheating.
理论解释了为什么人们会被驱使去出轨，但却很少有理论把这种责备归咎于伴侣。我认为这其中特别有趣的是这种一夫一妻制的文化决定论观念，以及如果历史有所不同，我们是否会认为出轨没那么糟糕。如果我们没有财产权或宗教的影响，这显然有点像幻想，但只是值得思考的事情。无论如何，又是一集节目，我还想顺便快速说一下，我今年收到了我的播客 Spotify 年度回顾，大家给予了太多的爱。你们所有人一直在收听，我真的非常非常感激。我想有那么一段时间我们在澳大利亚的排行榜上排在第24位，考虑到
I think cheating, you know, as hard as it is, is kind of common in our 20s as we're testing out our boundaries and how we communicate with partners and kind of experiencing sex and intimacy and emotional disclosure for the first time. We hear a lot of stories about it. Perhaps you've experienced it. So I hope this kind of shed some light on why it happens, the reasons around why people cheat, but also kind of expresses that I don't think it's ever someone's, like the person who's been cheated on's fault. There is so many. many theories that explain why people are driven to cheat, but so few theories that kind of put
我是用手机在堪培拉的卧室里录制的，这简直太疯狂了。所以非常感谢你们。如果你确实喜欢这个播客，并且觉得可以支持它更多，请在 Apple Podcasts 上给我们写一篇评论。这真的对社区和节目的成长很有帮助，能吸引更多人进来，为他们想讨论的内容带来新的想法，并且希望他们能像你一样从中受益。所以再次感谢大家的收听。下周，我们将讨论孤独心理学。
that blame on the partner. And I think especially interesting about this is this idea of that culturally conditioned idea of monogamy and whether we would see cheating as less bad if history had been different. If we didn't have the influence of property rights or religion, obviously that's a bit of a fantasy, but just kind of something to think about. Anyhow, another episode, I also I just want to quickly say I got my Spotify wrapped for my podcast this year and there was just so much love, you guys. You've all been listening so much and I really, really appreciate it like a lot. I think at one point we were like 24th in the charts in Australia, which is like insane considering
又是一个悲伤的话题。所以我希望我们都为此做好准备。再见。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧的迹象，
I record this on my phone in my Canberra bedroom. So thank you so much. And if you do like the podcast and you feel cool to support it more, please let write us a review on Apple Podcasts. It really helps the community and the show kind of grow, brings more people in to bring new ideas for what they want to discuss, and hopefully they get something out of it like you have. So thanks again for listening. Next week, we're talking about the psychology of loneliness.
健身，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立抗压能力。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一边成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。那是在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 TWO. percent。
Another sad one. So I hope we're all ready for that. See ya. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness,
在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我很重要。我是说。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代一样。
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
适应力，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养复原力。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你将会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听 2%。在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方搜索 TWO%。
On the Look Back at a podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm saying. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
在《Look Back》播客中。从 1979 年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。对我和我来说，84 年意义重大。我是说。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。在每一集中，我们挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过难关的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅聊 80 年代。
It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. Space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor.
那是非常疯狂的一年。那是非常疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了。在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听回顾。嘿，大家好！你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Kear Games 主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。而且，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，请在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcast 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《learn the hard way》。这是一档 iHeart 播客。保证真人。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。